- What's harder to win:
an NBA Finals or a Super Bowl?
- Super Bowl.
- Why?
- You only get one shot.
- Right.
- Cuz you could be a better
team 17 weeks out of 17
and still lose on that
Super Bowl Sunday.
♪♪♪
- Welcome to another
episode of "Full-Bodied."
I'm Channing Frye, here with
Cam Jordan, the pride and joy
of the Chandler Wolves.
Thank you for being
on the show with us.
As the wine gets darker, the
questions gonna get deeper.
- Hey, what's up?
How is everybody?
Wonderful.
Yes, Saints may or may not
win the Super Bowl this year.
Guarantee you that.
- You might be one of the
coolest people I've never met,
and I feel like I've met
a lotta cool people.
So, cheers, and we're gonna
get this thing started.
So this first one is
a sauvignon blanc.
And sav blanc is generally
known as like an old-school wine,
but a lot of people are
doing it differently now.
And so, my first question
is, how are the Saints
going to be better?
How are they gonna
reinvent themselves?
- You know, as we talk
about this wine,
it's definitely a
dawn of a new age.
You know, Drew
Brees just retired.
We're heading into a
new leadership position
in the quarterback room.
But at the same time,
in the last three years,
you've seen a
culture shift as well.
It hasn't just been the
New Orleans Saints offense.
You now have the
defense that comes too.
And so, when you think
about our defense,
we've got leadership at every position.
- Right, right.
- Where, you know, it's a stalwart,
where we can be dependable.
So I think that our leadership
will come from our defense.
But we talk about
offense, you still
have AK, which is probably the
best well-balanced, all-around,
running back you're gonna
catch in the league.
- You're making me wanna buy
a Saints jersey,
my friend. Shit.
- I mean, you talk about what
he's able to do on the field,
whether it's running
in between guards,
bouncing outside,
catching the rock.
I mean, the moment
he hits open space,
it's a full-blown problem.
I remember he came in his rookie
year and I tried to smack him.
- Yeah.
- Like, it's this training
camp and I was like, "I'mma
test what he's worth," you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so I went to go smash
him, and I think he like—
I lifted him at least
two feet in the air, you know?
- Right. At least.
- Like, he bounced.
I was like, I was like, "Good
hit. Clean hit. I love it."
I was like, "Welcome."
But he lands, plants
his foot down
and was, like, ready for the next move.
And I was like,
"Oh, he's different."
Luckily, it was out of bounds so he was—
- The play was over.
- It would have been tipped fair
had it been a game—
- It's like when you're late
for a rotation and somebody
goes to dunk and the
ball bounces real far—
- No doubt.
- You look— like, you see, you see
Jesus say, "You owe me one.
You owe me one."
- Exactly.
- Cuz I almost got boomed
on one time, and I was like,
"I woulda had to quit
playing basketball.
I woulda had to quit.
I can't go home. I can't
see my family. I can't see—
I gotta just, I gotta go work at Best Buy."
"Channing, what happened to you?"
"You saw it.
You saw I got dunked."
So this enthusiasm for
the game, and you've
been in there for a long
time for any NFL player.
You're a Pro Bowler. You're
from Chandler, Arizona.
And funny enough, I'm
So coming from where we
come from, why football?
- So Pops played in
the NFL for 13 years.
- I know that.
- Six-time Pro Bowler, Minnesota
Vikings. From Phoenix—
- Right.
- Went to South Phoenix.
Eighth grade rolls around,
I'm probably like 5' 8",
a buck 90-something, maybe 200.
- Woo.
- I might've been 200.
- Dang!
It's a very solid 200, it's just—
I'm still, I'm dunking, you know?
I'm dunking.
- So you're bouncing
to yourself.
- That's what I'm saying.
I'm very explosive.
I was a mini Zion,
you know what I'm saying?
Hey, I considered myself a point before
but it wasn't working out.
5' 9", I was on
the B-team. Like,
shit wasn't working out my way.
And then Pops was like, "I
don't wanna be that dad,
but here's your pads.
You got practice."
He just drops me off, throws
the pads at me, and I'm pissed.
And I'm sitting there at
practice like, "I
don't want this sh—."
Like, "What am I doing here?"
I was like, "I'm a hooper."
I was like, I'm like,
"Splash, water, that's me."
I'm looking up to guys like Amar'e, you know?
- Right. Right, right, right.
- Shawn Marion and Steve Nash.
I'm thinking, like, the
whole Suns roster.
I'm like, "Man, I'm going
to be one of them one day."
Like, "You're messing
up my dreams here."
- And then, moving on to college,
why Cal?
- Man.
- Why not Arizona?
Why not Arizona State?
- Arizona State had, like, that weird
college coach transition.
- Yeah.
Like, one coaching had gone out,
one coach is coming in.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then, Oregon
State really loved me.
Oregon State had a
lotta love for me,
but he kept wanting to
make me into a guard.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, he was like, "You could
be a Hall of Famer gold jacket
guard."
- Right.
- Like, I do way too much athletically
for me to be a fat person.
- [Laughing]
- And I'm trying—
- No offense to all the guards.
- All offense.
What do you mean?
I go out of my way to
make offense to offensive linemen.
You know like those
sloppy bigs in the league that
be like, "Oh,
you can't teach size"?
When somebody gets labeled,
"you can't teach size," you know?
Like, that's what he is.
He woke up and was
350 pounds, like, not trying.
- Who is somebody that you
are like, you respect ‘em
but you, like, love just mushing them?
It could be a quarterback,
it could be a running back, it could be a—
- It's an entire team.
I love the Atlanta Falcons, like, for
everything that they are.
Bruh, they're a phenomenal
team. They have top-tier talent
from quarterback Matt Ryan.
He had an MVP season in, what,
like, 2016, 2017?
They had Julio Jones
my entire career,
who just went over to Tennessee.
They just drafted this kid from
University of Florida, Kyle
Pitts.
I think he could
be special, but I'mma
put hands on
all of 'em regardless.
Like, I expect to win.
Like, the rivalry between
these two cities,
New Orleans and
Atlanta, is real.
- Crazy.
- And a lot of my
early career, it was
like, for us to get to the playoffs,
we'd have to beat Atlanta.
You know, like, we
go into Thanksgiving, "Hey,
we gotta beat
these Dirty Birds.
We beat them, we
lock in playoffs."
And we'd smack the
hell out of 'em, whether it
be at our house, their house.
We're eating turkey legs
on the 50-yard line.
We're singing, dancing.
And one, because there's never
been a defensive player to sack
one said quarterback
of a team more times
than what me and Matt
Ryan have together.
We have a special
symbiotic relationship.
Over 10 seasons, there's
been an amassed 21 sacks.
- Wow!
- Without him, I would
only have 73 sacks, you know?
I appreciate him for
at least a fourth.
- So we were just
talking about people
you love to shmack and lay down
and whisper sweet nothings to,
and that's obviously Matt Ryan.
Who in your opinion are
the top five quarterbacks
right now in today's game?
- [Whistling] Man, and I'll say, when
you say top five,
it's like when you get
to that top one tier,
you can, like, interchange them,
you know? My dawg
Drew just retired
so I don't have to worry about
putting him in his tier.
- Right, right, right.
- So then, you got Russ Wilson,
Aaron Rodgers, Matthew Stafford—
- Ooh!
- Big arm. Pat Mahomes,
and then I'm either tied.
It's either Tom
Brady or Lamar Jack.
Tom Brady is fighting for
fifth because he's the most accomplished.
- Yeah.
- But if you look at, like, stat lines, throws,
whatever it is, you wouldn't
be like, "He's clearly top two."
- He just, he is Chris Paul when
it comes to the game.
He's gonna nickel
and dime every mistake.
"Man, you gonna
give me this?
Boop, OK, five yards."
- He's so methodical
in what he does.
He's the most accomplished
NFL player probably ever.
- Is he the GOAT?
- When I think GOAT, I
think, like, Deion Sanders.
- OK, OK.
- I think athletically,
like, gift from God.
- Right.
- You know what I'm saying?
Like, one of those Megatrons,
one of the APs, you know, the Bo Jacksons.
You look at him,
you're like, "Bro, GOAT."
- Yeah.
- I look at Tom, and I'm like,
most accomplished ever.
- Right.
- But I just think my athletic GOAT—
probably cuz I messed
up and said athletic GOAT—
I don't think quarterbacks
are in that realm of GOAT talk
because I think they can Ben
Roethlisberger this thing.
I think, you know, they could be
possible Hall of Famers and—
- Never work out.
When I retired
from basketball, I
realized that wine was my
dream outside of the dream,
and I also realized
I had to do it
my way by creating my own wine
label, Chosen Family Wines.
And in this segment,
we're gonna dive
into my guest's dreams,
brought to you by Porsche.
So we got this cab franc.
This is actually delicious,
this Palazzo.
And I think for me, cab
franc is that usually this
is something that's mixed
in with other things.
You're starting your
own podcast, "Big Truss,"
which I checked out.
- "Big Truss," Season 2.
- You're into fashion.
You're a Team Jordan guy.
So, Cam, what is one of the
greatest accomplishments
of your career so far?
- You know, I feel like
in my life, I've
probably cried three times.
Once when I was born—
- [Laughing] Get outta here!
- The first time my mama
gave me an ass whoopin'—
- Come on.
- And the time my wife
said we were
pregnant with a son.
And I was like, it
comes full circle.
My dad had me. I'm blessed
to play in the league.
It was like, "Yo,
the legacy continues."
And I'm big on legacy.
- Yeah.
- I appreciate everything
that I've ever
learned from both my parents.
- What is your dream job
after hanging it up?
- Had you asked me that
my first five years in
the league, my dream job
would have been a P.E. teacher.
I was like, "Bro, I'm
gonna be a P.E. teacher."
- Dude, what do you think I
went to college for?
- Huh.
- Well, you have to get your
P.E. teacher degree to coach.
I wanted to coach high school.
- Whatever I do, I'm
always in the community,
I'm always trying to impart
some sort of knowledge on kids.
Earlier this last week,
I was at a football camp.
But it's like, just
talking to these kids,
they try and draw so
much knowledge from you,
but they give back
so much energy.
It's a give and take,
and it's like, bro,
that's how I swear people
stay youthful forever.
- But you're into podcasting.
So you have your podcast.
- Hey, big "Truss Levels."
- Big Truss.
Yeah, yeah, just released.
- Your episodes are funny.
- Appreciate it.
- You're really good, and I
think your guys' chemistry is
worth people's watch.
So where did that come from?
- My boy, we got
drafted together. We
played in New Orleans
for eight years together.
I was like, bro, like, between
me and him, we know at least 50 percent
of the league.
- Yeah.
- I was like, "We could have
fun calling people in,
whatever it is.
- Yeah, totally.
- Just talk—It's talking shit
and having fun.
- Totally.
- Who doesn't like that?
- It's the best.
This personality of yours,
were you always like this
or was there somebody
that, like, you would say
inspired you to be like this?
- Nah, it got me a lot of ass
whoopins when I was younger.
Yeah, I've always been this.
- Like, for instance, you
send wine to somebody—
- It was a beautiful
bottle of Jordan cab.
I mean—
- Jordan is delicious.
- I sent him my best vintage too.
I sent him a 2011.
I really enjoy that year.
- That's a great year.
- It was a phenomenal year.
- I said that the other day!
- I'm just sayin'.
- Tell the story of who you
sent the wine to and why.
- We had trounced the
Carolina Panthers.
- Trounced is a wild word.
- So we, yeah, we beat them
the first time,
and I think it was a close game.
We beat 'em the
second time, and I
think it was a little
bit farther stretched.
So now, they've got some
salt in their wounds.
You know, the first game, I think I got a
question about how fashionable
he was.
And I was like, "Oh, yeah, you know,
he's got auntie swag on 1,000.
- [Laughing]
- You know, and it was like—
- Auntie swag! That was when he was
doing the scarf joint?
- No, I think this was right before
the—whatever, whatever it is.
- Before the scarf joint.
- Yeah, yeah. And he's like, "I peep
at his swag too."
And it was like, it was like, it
was like, one of these playful,
disrespectful jabs, Bam, bam.
It was a two-piece.
And I was like, I was
like "That sorta hurts."
I think it was the third
game that pissed me off.
He was, like, warming
up on our side, right?
He's got these TRX bands going.
He's throwing.
And I'm like, "Bro, I've got
nothing but respect for you.
But you being over
here is messing up my—
- Juju.
- Yeah, like my feng shui,
my zen, my happiness.
And I'm like, "I'mma
let this shit rock, right?"
I think I get a sack
on him in that game.
And so we beat 'em three times
in a row. Like, that's so tough.
Like, that's—
- So tough, especially in football—
- Yeah.
- With injuries and
stuff going on.
- And so I think I made a
statement like, "You know,
he likes my sauce. I'mma
send him some juice."
And then so I sent him a
great bottle of cab.
He's too much of
a baller for me.
When I think one of those
physical specimens, he's it.
- Yeah.
Like, my first time I ever hit
Cam Newton, our rookie year,
I hit him dead in the chest.
And he eats it, turns and,
like, runs for another 15.
And I'm like "Oh, shit."
- [Laughing] "You different."
- "Quarterbacks are different."
- Yeah, they different.
- Quarterbacks are different.
He's different.
- He's a big dude.
I'm like, "Yo, it's him,
and there's LeBron James."
And then I met LeBron and I
was like, "He's a little skinnier
than I thought."
He's basketball big.
- He's 270.
- He's basketball big.
On a 6'9" frame.
- That's huge for a point guard.
- On a 6'9" frame. Right. Zion is big.
- When I think—
- Zion is big.
- When I think big,
I'm like, "Zion's big."
Like, 6'7", but 2—
- 285.
- Whatever, but looks it.
You know what I'm saying?
- He's 6'6".
- Like, you could, huh—
- Oh, yeah. You different.
- And be like, "Oh, you like that." Yeah, yeah.
- He built.
- I feel like if I did this to LeBron,
LeBron would shift a little.
- So what NBA player would—
other than Zion,
injuries aside right now—
that you think would be
a good football player?
- Is this panning all time in my
mind or is this just like right
now?
- I'll say,
tet's say all time
and then right now.
So two players.
- I'll say Big Baby definitely
could have been a 3-tech.
- He played, I think
he played football.
- That's what I'm saying.
I think he played a little bit.
- He was supposed
to go to, like, LSU.
- I mean, he had the
size, the wherewithal.
He could have been a pure 3.
- He was quick too, shockingly
quick for his size.
- Yup.
- And physical.
- I think LeBron would have
been a phenomenal tight end,
would have been—
- Ooh, tight end.
- I don't know if he'd
ever play wide receiver.
- Nah, nah, nah.
- He just, he was too tall. Like,
he'd have no knees.
You're 6'9"
running down there.
I'm not—like, no
one in our safety line
is ever gonna be like, "Oh,
yeah, I'm gonna go up top with him."
- No.
- You know?
- Taking them shins off.
- Absolutely.
- We've talked about basically
everybody else except for you.
And so for me, it's
just kinda like when
we start talking
about you, we
gotta bring out the good stuff.
It's a Nickel & Nickel.
They're an awesome
place to go visit.
I love their tasting room.
Their winemakers are cool too.
Shout-out to Joe and Phil.
You have established yourself
not only as a Pro Bowler,
as a leader—you're different.
But you're different
in a good way.
And I think you're leading a new
generation of guys who are not
hiding behind the helmet.
- These '90s kids definitely
don't hide behind helmets.
- You've not missed a game ever.
- God is good.
- What's different about you?
- My mother prayed
for me every day?
I don't know. You know what I'm sayin'?
There's some luck.
There's some blessings
that have been passed down.
And this idea of attrition.
I mean, when I
think longevity, I
think about, you know, when I was younger.
I never really understood.
Like, Pops retired
when I was, like, four,
you know? My mom, she
was our first goalie,
first quarterback,
first whatever.
You know, she did
it all with us.
And you just don't ever
think about stopping.
It's just having that
motor that doesn't stop.
I look at my dad.
He still works out
five times a week.
- Man, you know what I'm sayin'?
- Oh, your dad. Stop it!
- He's a legend.
Like, I'll be like, bro, it took two sons
to equal one dad, you know?
- Yeah.
- Like, I got the football world,
but my dad also went to Brown.
So he's an engineer.
So, brother does the
engineering thing.
But it all comes down to, it's
like, the more you can do.
Like, whatever you think you're
doing, you can always do more.
- Yeah.
- So I sort of live like that
1 percent better every day rule.
And in that, you know, being
blessed with health.
And, like, everybody's had nicks.
- Nagging injuries. Yeah, yeah.
- Nags, whatever it is.
You know, "Oh, I've got a herniated
disc." Whatever, you know, whatever it is.
- "Oh, I have a herniated disc?"
- Yeah, you play 12 games
on it. Whatever that is.
- I didn't play one game because
my stomach hurt one time.
- This is the basketball
mentality that we talk about
in the locker room.
Like, I've gone to the sideline
and relocated my finger.
- Same here. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Same here.
None of these have
not been dislocated.
- Dislocate 'em, you
pop 'em back in
and you keep on going.
It's like "Oh, Cam,
but you broke a rib."
So? It was a rib.
- What?!
- How many other ribs do we have?
- See, I don't know about that.
I never broke a rib.
Obviously cuz I'm
not tackling other 300-pound
human beings, but—
- My conditioning mentally
is, if I'm not on the field,
who's on the field?
- Oh, yeah.
- You what I'm saying?
My condition is,
it's like if I'm
trying to get my team
to be as close as we
can to be the
strongest link, there
can be no weak link.
- Right.
- And I feel like when
I'm on the field,
I am our best available option.
So when it comes down to games,
I've played in almost every one
of 'em.
I didn't start
one my rookie year
because I wasn't in on
some sub-package, which
pissed me off, and it inspired me to
be like, "All right, well, shit.
If I can't be on
this nickel package,
they're gonna see
me as a defensive end."
I'mma be a
one through four.
If there's a fifth
down, I want it.
And I have to—
I'll fight coaches
on the sidelines.
Like, "Hey, Cam,
you're out this rep."
"You're out this rep!"
Like, "What do you mean?!
These are my reps."
And it's like, so, when
you look back at it,
it's like, "Hey, Cam, you know,
you've played 160 games."
I'm not even looking
forward to that.
I'm looking forward
the next snap.
You know, I'm always
looking ahead.
I'm looking towards
the next play,
what gets me closer
to the season.
- So we're gonna play a
new game called "NBA or NFL."
And the first question
is what's harder to win:
an NBA Finals or a Super Bowl?
- Super Bowl.
- Why?
- You only get one shot, one game.
And the NBA Finals
are seven games.
Super Bowl, it's you can
win any given Sunday.
Cuz you could be a better
team 17 weeks out of 17
and still lose on that
Super Bowl Sunday.
- OK, so I don't
disagree with you.
But you said how hard is it to
beat the same team three times.
- No doubt.
- So think about a team that
is equally as good as you,
that you played twice
already, that you
gotta beat four times.
- If it's a sweep, I'd
say the Finals then.
- OK. [Laughing]
- But if it's—
- Just very evenly matched.
- It's harder to
win a Super Bowl.
Because it's 2-2.
If it ends up 3-3, it's
harder to win. Like,
it all comes down—
now you guys are really—
- It just comes down to one game.
- Yeah, it just comes
down to one game.
- OK, OK.
- Super Bowl, it is just one game.
You better have your A-game.
- The A-game.
- Like, Pat Mahomes out
there balling, but he
had no offensive linemen.
- Right.
- That's your only Sunday you had
to show up and win the Super Bowl.
- Who's more unguardable:
LeBron or Derrick Henry?
- Ooh.
Which LeBron are
we talking about?
- We're talking about 2016 LeBron.
- 2016, 2017 LeBron is hard to—
whew, that's tough.
Derrick Henry, you just gotta
catch him going lateral.
Cuz if he's coming downhill,
you're not stopping him.
I'll probably say it's
harder to guard LeBron.
- OK.
- That's like Giannis
coming down full steam.
- Nah, nah, nah.
- Like, you're gonna—it's
either a foul or a bucket.
- Last question,
top to bottom, who
has better athletes:
football or basketball?
- Top to bottom.
Man, that's tough.
Cuz I was initially gonna
say football, easily said.
Some of our D-linemen
can easily match anybody
on a basketball roster.
But then I thought about it.
If I say your top 10 versus
my top 10, we'd easily have way more.
- So you would say—we've had this
conversation before.
But we had it with all sports.
- Right.
- We go, who's your top
athlete for football?
You would say a wide receiver
or a cornerback right?
- Maybe.
- Right?
- I might say D-lineman.
- OK, a D-lineman.
Who's the most athletic
D-lineman in the NFL right now?
- [Whistling]
- Pure athleticism.
- Either Chase Young
or Myles Garrett.
- Oh, Myles Garrett's a freak.
- A freak of nature.
6'6",
270. 43-inch vertical.
- He's built like an armadillo.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah. He's—
- 4.5 40.
- OK—
- Freak of nature.
- So Myles Garrett—
- Yep.
- Right, for you is our—
- Who's your most athletic player?
- Wow.
I would have to say
prime Russell Westbrook.
- OK. Yeah, absolutely.
- So those two would be there.
Now who's your least athletic?
- Oof.
- Yeah.
- That's why I was initially
gonna say football,
but I was like, if
you take all of us,
like, our offensive linemen
are gonna hold us back.
- Quarterbacks will
hold you back too.
Tom Brady is not that fast.
- No doubt.
Cuz as we talked
about earlier,
quarterbacks are not gonna be
that athletic in the old mold.
Right now—
- Now it's different.
It's different.
- I mean—
- Quarterbacks are very different.
- Yeah. Dak Prescott
and Lamar, Russell Wilson,
Aaron Rodgers, even.
I'm more worried about where
the quarterback's gonna be.
- Aaron Rodgers be moving like that?
- Oh, he's a phenomenal
finesser in the pocket.
- Stop it.
- Bro, cuz he has
the arm to do so.
He'll throw 50 off the back leg,
just chillin'. Like, off a fly-by,
about to get smacked.
I'm more worried about
where a quarterback is
than I am an offensive
lineman. Not to take away
from an offensive
lineman, but I do.
I just think as a natural
enemy, like, they are
speed bumps that get in my way.
- Right.
They are a cobra.
You are a mongoose.
- They are like an alligator.
And I would be like a cheetah.
Like, they could
overpower me, sure,
but how can they catch me?
- If you get pancake-blocked,
do you just hate yourself?
- No, because everybody gets got.
But I'mma get
them more than I get got.
- Let me think of who's
the slowest—oh,
Jared Dudley, by far.
- Don't—look, look, that's
a hot name for me.
- Big Spudley Dudley!
That's my guy. I played with him.
- I make fun of him—
- He's one of the best
teammates of all times.
- I've gone, I go out of my way
to make fun of Jared Dudley
because as an athlete, he
is the opposite of what
I think is athleticism.
- He has athletic hands. We
used to make this joke.
He has athletic hands.
This is probably one of
my favorite interviews.
You're the first NFL player
we've had on the show.
- As much shit as I talked,
I'm probably the last, but—
- No! No, we want that.
We need that.
I loved introducing
these wines to you,
having sips with you.
Good luck this season.
- I appreciate you
having me, especially
knowing another Arizona boy.
In fact, a Chandler boy.
- East Valley guy.
Come on now.
- Look, C-Town's finest, always standing up.
- There you go.
- To be in the same space,
I'm just blessed with the
opportunity to pop up.
- Awesome.
- And I'm always here
for a good cab.
- Cheers.
♪♪♪